how's it going breasts my name is
Barrett back welcome back to some more
Silent Hill we are actually gonna go
back to the boss fight where we killed
Cheryl I kill her that gives you bad
endings it's a penguin higher than an
icon and I'm not really doing this
because I care about good ending or bad
ending every [ __ ] let's play I make
there's always always everyone just
wants the good ending and I don't know I
liked about anything I really do
in a lot of games the bad ending are
more memorable sup penguin can you tell
me where Cheryl is cuz I'm lost
there it is alright I don't know it's
more fun more memorable more and more
tipsy Topsy jiggly pop see also I'm
sorry I haven't been uploading these
videos as frequent as the others there's
only so many videos each day that I can
actually upload so it's it's hard for me
and since Walking Dead came out I had to
put this on ice for a couple of days
alright let's do this come on Cheryl
this is the bottle that we got in the
beginning of your met don't slap me
Sharon how can I do it out slap Cheryl's
up how do i there we go alright take
this lotion [ __ ] works every time
but just love ocean ocean Oh disgusting
oh that's right kill it
Sybil wake up snap out of it
Sybil snip it snappy [ __ ] out of that
what happened
just gave birth to a demon spawn Shh
don't talk I'll take care of you yeah
Harry
why did they take your daughter so this
is different from buying a fire I'm not
sure myself but you know Cheryl isn't my
biological daughter
I actually haven't told her yet you
haven't told us either she probably
already knows anyway though probably we
found her abandoned on the side of the
highway nobody knew where she came from
we didn't have any kids of her own all
right guy my wife was sick yeah and it
didn't look like she was getting any
better
oh well so we took Cheryl in this is
[ __ ] creepy so in that case I always
get goosebumps when I say this game
there might be some connection between
Cheryl and this town let's feel like
that pony's gonna jump off and eat
Michael what do you do now
Cheryl a daughter
yeah I will save her no matter what
that's right we will save her bread I
still don't know if I will get actually
get the good ending or not no come on
I'm serious
they have a clips are in the clip so why
you know what
all right if the if if this last room
doesn't wearing I'll I'll do they're
really sad please work please but I
can't get it out how much I pull then
use this yes yes that actually makes
sense
no you just take it and drag it out I'm
a fine pole or whatever do what you want
PFOA fell well that's convenient
let's go to Oh bill I'll feel my day hey
you are I used to see about yeah hello
no one's around huh I don't have a map
we've been here before for sure I
remember that
[Music]
that is jammed lovely that is luck
lovely that is not lovely that is not
lovely what what is going on here okay
goosebumps coming back because I don't
know about this this is a puzzle it is
[ __ ] here
can I click all of these I can
there on the wall let me check em the
goat is for is it that straightforward
crab is 10 the way it's 2 and the
Dolphins are 0 there anymore so I'm
supposed to see a resemblance with those
numbers and then make something about
these ok so that kind of shapes like a
zero can that be
okay it's the number of legs that in the
picture so I don't know if the tail
counts no yes all right it was for dead
it yeah yeah I have to change there's a
sort of time take it why the [ __ ] not
would I not want the Sun if I don't be
ridic
baki oh [ __ ] yo don't even try [ __ ] lie
down and stay down alright that's it
[ __ ] let's check all the doors ah lovely
but I do have the stone of time sounds
like I'm playing legend of Sons I was
some [ __ ] like that what does it say
names engraved on a lilac rim grim the
Reapers list yes the head count is set
young and old line up in order of age
then the pathway opens awaiting them the
frenzied uproar and the feasts of death
I love basting on that oh here's another
one
[Music]
so many puzzles so you were supposed to
arrange the orders in the poem or
whatever and spell them from the
youngest to the oldest I think and that
should spell alert and that other than
that I did not so bad myself actually
lock that up in case you thought I was
smart there for a second oh you were
wrong
what yeah thank you have a compliment
I'm gonna keep playing that what alright
imma let of Solomon you know you don't
mind that I take it it's gonna borrow it
for a minute it's gonna be evil people
Harry I hear candy sir what's the matter
with them they've had it now why I'm
still alive even though everyone else is
dead I'm not the only one who's still
walking around I'm the same as them no
you're not Lisa just hadn't noticed it
before don't worry about it Lisa
stay by me Harry please I'm so scared
help me save me from them please Harry
this is so sad hey don't push it away
man what the thigh
[Music]
[ __ ] intense man
thank you later
[Music]
come on man hurry don't walk around soon
escape this full of surprises
I just [ __ ] love that part
it's beautiful music
[Music]
Parris dancin
that
[Music]
ah there's his diet on the floor as dr.
- let me quit being in charge of that
patient it's too weird still alive but
with wounds that won't heal told the
doctor I quit one work at that house
cannot anymore
the room is filled with insects even
with doors and windows shut they get
into spite me to the hospital
feeling bad needed throw up but nothing
comes out vomiting only violent blood
and puts flow from the bathrooms life I
said I try to stop it but it won't turn
up new drug
[Music]
for Lisa
so
wait it's not it
[Music]
generally
poor Lisa
[Music]
nope that's good and then we need to use
the clock the time thing I don't know
what it's called stun of time
Mike Suns doesn't it certain of time but
to have the IV breast oh [ __ ]
you don't have to explode in my face
that's what she said key of hairy giris
hi girls with a good guy I think it was
in Harry Potter at some point nowhere
that's a nice place to be
alright let's go in cube is this here
no I like wherever that is
this is Opia where's Pollock I mean the
other one okay
some of the different Amiens
[Applause]
I guess second floor I don't know where
else to go I don't like this
I'm not big fan of this ambience
come at me ladies
you can't see [ __ ] huh this seems really
nice
Christa mercury ah shut up please so
many trophies ring of contract
alright I'm a [ __ ] robber
this is Webby oh hi make it ha ha ha
alright
hi goddammit
back off this is definitely not good no
if you don't like it then you should've
put a hammer than you okay that's a
no-no that's a no-no if you don't like
it then you should've better hang of it
if you like it then you shut up
[Music]
I know that have been in here I'm an
idiot I'm an idiot
can we go here yes okay
hello my one shot one kill
I hate when the angle [ __ ] me over and
I don't know how many I'm dealing with
[Applause]
that's right
oh she wasn't that all right what do we
got over here
that's another stone screwed to the wall
well good thing we have a screw screw
this cracker all right what is this now
take it up Harry there's a key
electricity is flowing to the team
I'll get shocked
Oh unknown material I'm just trying
everything cuz I'm an idiot okay so we
need something to do by that electric
there they go I think it's really cute
what are you doing I really appreciate
it
they're all lights come on I hear this
one I look I'll take you supposed to be
a camera here somewhere
could this be it yeah it is I think
that's a camera
yes all right anything else
all right go let's take pictures of dead
bodies no that's not cool fine fine I
don't do it
okay what do we got I hit the third
floor the elevator doesn't appear wait
which elevator did I take that was
actually working we need to take that
one that is actually working I think
it's up ahead and hit the third fluff
baby
what happens if all right and we need to
take that uh ambience
don't be mean to me abeyance the light
to the future
oh [ __ ] me
[Music]
what okay let's take another one uh
all right the light illuminating the
darkness charlie good that's nice ah
[Music]
okay
so yeah like a favorite if you enjoyed
this episode
I think last one or one other and then
that should be banding of this sales and
breath you know I love you
[Music]